il est un peu plus de 7 heures le
feeling le bateau de parcs canada nous a
t-on à la marina près de sydney sur
l'île de vancouver
il faudra environ une heure pour se
rendre sur les berges de l'ill darcis la
plus au sud du parc national des îles
golf c'est un endroit paisible où les
gens viennent aujourd'hui pour profiter
des plages et le soleil mais il ya un
siècle s'est elle était plutôt connu
comme l'île de la mort
ces gens étaient pratiquement tous
originaires de chine entre 1891 dès 1924
une cinquantaine de personnes ont été
envoyées sur cette petite île à l'époque
où la ville de victoria était
responsable du lazaret ces
établissements où l'on isole des malades
contagieux les hommes de l'île d'ars y
était complètement laissés à eux mêmes
au
moins une douzaine d'entre eux y ont
péri ce que nous sommes venus visiter ce
sont les ruines de la maison du gardien
en 1907 lorsque le gouvernement fédéral
a pris le contrôle de ce qui est
essentiellement une colonie l'épreuve
les conditions ont changé et du
personnel de soin a été envoyé et le
racisme lui a persisté
les malades ont donc été transféré sur
une petite île voisine
la sociologue réunissent à mawani
s'intéresse à cette période depuis une
vingtaine d'années une histoire qui l'a
choquée
à la même époque d'autres patients
atteints de la maladie de hansen était
envoyé dans un hôpital du nouveau
brunswick où il recevait des soins leur
différence il était blanc
aujourd'hui sur l'île la nature a repris
ses droits le lazaret a été réduit en
cendres il ya bien longtemps seuls les
ruines de la maison du gardien et une
petite plaque installée par la ville de
victoria peuvent encore témoigner de ce
que beaucoup qualifient être l'une des
pages les plus sombres du racisme au
canada ici ça aix en othe radio canada
sur l'île d'asie